I guess you can suit of course doesn't
fit me so should become an Avenger other
like trials or listen I know school
sucks I know you want to save the world
but this does not mean you're an Avenger
the world's changing boys
time we change too
this invader stay close to the ground
stay out of trouble you're not ready
this is my chance to prove myself don't
mess with I'll kill you and everybody in
the world I want you to understand
[Music]
how to be nice touch my family hey
youtubers new spider-man footage and we
got our first look at the tinkerer who
all explained in how Ironman literally
helps create like physically and
metaphorically helps create the villain
so it goes way deeper than you thought
is a new brand of the Spider Man
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so really like the important
stuff first it's like a slightly
different remix version of the trailer
just a little more hype I do like the
music a little bit more they've been a
lot of Marvel trailers this year with
pop songs that can go either way but
like the new big things that they're
showing off is a better look at the
villains so you know the vulture is
basically the big bat of the movie
Adrian Toomes he runs a crew of people
that clean up big accidents of the MCU
after the Avengers and big villains get
in fights and trash cities that was one
of the biggest jokes about movies during
26 large-scale urban destruction both on
the Marvel side and on the DC side
especially after age of Ultron like look
at this city that Iron Man and Hulk just
absolutely trashed even Robert Downey
jr. in real life responded to that and
it's like you know I kind of feel like
Tony Stark would have paid to clean that
up but it's a long-running joke of the
movies that they never really addressed
that so the use of the vulture and the
Iron Man characters just provided an
opportunity to pick that up and run with
it so the way he talks about himself is
he's just like a blue-collar working man
trying to take care of his crew and
they're trying to take care of their
families they lose their livelihood
because Tony Stark starts the
government-sponsored damage control and
basically steals their work out from
under them so we found out recently
marveled actually does have the rights
to do the scrolls if they do secret
invasion and they completely trash the
earth Tony Stark's new government
organization is going to roll in and
clean that up
that's a lot of work that the vultures
crew would have gotten so you seen the
shocker you've seen Donald Glover's
character one of the other big
characters the tinkerer just hasn't
appeared yet but finally we have a look
at him here and he's sort of like Adrian
Toomes the vultures right-hand man so
the way they described him is the Tony
Stark starts the damage control they
announced it as you see in the trailer
here but they say that puts him Adrian
Toomes in a pretty desperate situation
so with the trucks they've already
loaded up he and his crew with the help
of a character called the tinkerer
starts stealing more of this exotic tech
Chitauri dark elf from Thor the dark
world and even some stark stuff which I
totally love
so they retrofit it and sell it on the
black market so that's where you see
spider-man trying to stop them on the
ferry
you missed the illegal weapons ferry you
hear I'm talking to Iron Man about in
the trailer these weapons are crazy
dangerous so one you're going to see a
lot of Easter eggs for the other movies
we already know about the Captain
America Civil War with the shocker here
using a modified version of crossbones
gauntlet as he punches spider-man this
looks like it's later in the movie
because he's lost the suit so presumably
happening after the fairies save but it
doesn't stop there if you remember the
daredevil TV series when he went to see
Melvin Potter
there were Easter eggs all over there
for like stilt man all kinds of
gladiators stuff stuff that you might
not ever actually see happen on the
series but for other big movies and
other big comic book adventures so it
sounds like they're going to drop him in
the next trailer that they post we'll
probably get a good look inside his lair
so just keep your eyes peeled when that
happens for all the Easter eggs for all
the other movies but the cool thing
about the Tinker character even though
he's mostly this old man in the comics
he's actually helped out a bunch of
other villain for kingpin for
diamondback that makes you think about
Luke Cage like who maybe there's a
connection there to be had even if the
Marvel Netflix characters never make it
on screen and infinity war or any of the
big Avengers films you can still connect
them with people like the Tinker people
like Melvin Potter but then there was
Hobgoblin Eddie Brock and I joke a
little bit about connecting this to
daredevil he actually did work for stilt
man who still showed up in Melvin Potter
shop so there already is a bit of a
spider-man homecoming daredevil
connection so let me know in the
comments they actually did say that they
wanted to do something with the Netflix
characters the producers of spider-man
homecoming because they're in Queens
Daredevils in Hell's Kitchen
spider-man's going to be spending a
little bit of time in Manhattan even
though a lot of his adventure is going
to be jumping around all over New York
City but typically it's a lot harder to
actually get like physical cameos on
screen so in the absence of that you
have little things in the background
like this like connections from pre
adventures like where did these stilts
come from what was that all about who
was he working with well now we know he
was actually working with the tinkerer
helping out stilt man create his tech
what about Diamondback and Luke Cage he
got a lot of his weapons from Hammer
Tech who was another person that was
stuck in Seagate prison they just kind
of drugged Justin Hammer through the mud
but he got thrown in Seagate after
Ironman to in like a lot of really rich
billionaires was still able to use his
money while he was locked up for his
benefit so like his company goes on
selling all kinds of weapons all over
the world because Stark does not sell
weapons but like they say there's a lot
of left over stark tech that the vulture
commandeered so part of his flight suit
is going to be a little bit of stark
tech I like the idea that they're almost
making Iron Man seem like a villain in
this like look you helped create this
person even though you didn't mean to
you caused so many problems that was
kind of the theme of civil war is that
even when you're trying to do good
things it all just goes to [ __ ] I
totally love all this Easter Egg stuff
in the background but I know this is
very Ironman heavy most of the rest of
the trailers in the footage we see will
focus on spider-man's perspective on all
this so Ironman is sort of the guy that
just like enters the story briefly
shakes his fist takes the suit back then
goes back to stark tech maybe gives them
his suit back at the end of the movie as
a couple funny quips participates in a
quick adventure and that's about it it's
still spider-man's movie it's just that
most of the trailers wanted to hype up
his presence so it makes it seem like
there's a lot more of him than there
actually is in the movie but there's a
whole bunch of stuff happening tonight
this actually just dropped so I wanted
to post it as quick as possible I do
have that x-men gifted trailer I had to
sit on that I had to get permission from
Fox to post that so as soon as they give
me the thumbs up I'll post that every
once in a while I do have to ask for
permission to post up like this but the
cool thing is is that I'm doing like a
special Logan blu-ray giveaway because
that also drops so that'll happen when I
post that gifted trailer but all kinds
of DC stuff happening if there's new
Superman footage I'll post up later
tonight there's going to be all kinds of
flash tomorrow so while you wait at the
post you can click here for brand new
Justice League and you can click here
for more spider-man homecoming thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you
tonight